بالفعل عبد السلام حاله هرج ومرج هنا امام
المحكمه وصوره مختلطه ما بين مناصريه
ترامب ووسائل الاعلام وايضا اشخاصهم
مناهضون لترامب سنتحرك قليلا بالكاميرا
مثلا ترى هذه اللافته بان ترامبلا احد فوق
القانون ولكن يتجمع حول هذه السيده عدد من
مناصري ترامبو الذين يقولون انهم يقفون مع
الرئيس الامريكي السابق عدد الذين
يتواجدون هنا يعني من ملاحظه سريعه بما
اننا وصلنا قبل لحظات فقط يبدو ان مناصريه
رمب عددهم اكبر من المناهضين ولكن
يعني الوضع سلمي كان هناك مخاوف مخاوف من
ان تكون هناك بعض مخاوف امنيه من ان يكون
عدد المتظاهرين بالالاف العدد لا باس به
ليست الارقام التي كنا قد سمعناها من عمده
ميامي والشرطه هنا الذين قالوا انهم
يتوقعون او جاهزون للتعامل ما بين مع
متظاهرين يبلغ عددهم ما بين 5000 الى 50
الفا المئات ربما هنا ولكن الوضع سلمي
ولكن هناك حاله فوضى ولافت ان الشرطه كما
ترون لم تضع اي سياج حديدي مثلا يفصل
المتظاهرين عن وسائل الاعلام او يفصل
المتظاهرين عن المتظاهرين المضادين مثل ما
مثلا راينا في منهات في نيويورك قبل نحو
شهرين حين مثل ترامب امام المحكمه هناك
ايضا ما ترون هنا ما يفصل هؤلاء
المتظاهرون عن مبنى المحكمه هو هذا ربما
الشريط الاصفر فقط يعني
في منهات كان هناك سياج حديدي وكان هناك
اغلاق كامل
للمشهد هنا المشهد مختلط ومختلف تماما
ولكنه سلمي ونسمع هتافات كما كنا قد
سمعناها بالامس امام مقر اقامه ترامب في
ميامي دورال حيث كنت وقبل قليل النحو 10
الى 20 شخص الذين كانوا هنا يقفون مع
ترامب يرون ان هذه عمليه مسيسه